secondo voi quanti i giudici
sono
fondamentalmente
quelli belli
quelli brutti
e quelli inutili
puoi ma soltanto tu puoi
cdc
che il gioco più valgo zelig -
finito che abbia mai giocato
campeggio italy quando questi
critici e fare un gioco di
camion
se non l'avete mai sentito non
ti preoccupare neanch'io fino a
poche settimane fa ero a
conoscenza di questo scempio
ho letto qualche recensione
qualche sito qui e là david ha
voluto un emerito
maestra 10
e subito d betitaly
uao
dopo pasti funny gioco tanto da
vendere una delle recensioni
abbastanza
ok guardate vi faccio vedere uno
screenshot del gioco
visto avevano così non sembra
poi tanto male povero giuro
credetemi sulla parola
fa schifo
veramente schifo
ed è con 5 motivi per cui di
pizzo dovrebbe essere mai e poi
mai comprato
numero 5
i piccoli errori
di nuovo o di fatali
perché sono staccati dal
cavallo
questo non ha senso che ti amo i
cani vanno visti programmatori
puoi il cronometro
mondo di patty costato poco
spostare g2play pixel che la
compongono
polietilene non sono molto
grande luccalavoro queste cose
si potrebbero evitare benissimo
numero quattro
il primo impatto
anche qui
non è fondamentale
perugia e quando fate partire il
gioco non appare neanche il logo
della casa produttrice l'uomo
dei programmatori
e come se non bastasse
posta rete scherzando
4cam solo 4 cam
solo 4
numero 3
assenza di convertitore
ok sta partendo la gara
pronti via rossi
roma
unione sarda
perché nastri
scusate se pretendo tuo cuore ma
quando compro un video gioco di
corse vorrei che i competitori
albero cuccagna già solo
perchè dovrebbero arrivare e
microtomo
numero 2
assenza di fisica guardate qua
non c'è neanche bisogno di
commentare
il cane si comporta esattamente
come se non avessi preso proprio
persico po' galeotti fisica di
questo
numero 1
il trapasso degli oggetti
la prima volta scugnizzi a praga
è capitato questo
ahahah ma che cacchio
si sono completamente
dimenticata di rende
sono tutti gli oggetti
tutti gli alberi le casette gli
avversari il caccia di ponte
non riesco
immaginami la donna che si fa,
poi
eroina cocaina
smartis
e quel sorriso neanche pagare
per giocare questa roba
boom deliro
l'unica cosa decente che ci si
può fare con successo a calci
chiavetta tagliarsi le vene
per favore
non compratelo
dopo averlo prestare e non
scaricatelo